>> WE ARE PUTTING THE HARSHEST,
STRONGEST, MOST STRINGENT
SANCTIONS ON IRAN.
I HOPE TO BE ABLE TO MAKE A DEAL
WITH THEM, A GOOD DEAL, A FAIR
DEAL, A GOOD DEAL FOR THEM,
BETTER FOR THEM.
BUT WE CANNOT ALLOW THEM TO HAVE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
WE MUST BE ABLE TO GO TO A SITE
AND CHECK THAT SITE.
WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO GO INTO
THEIR MILITARY BASES TO SEE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE
CHEATING.
>> Sean: THAT WAS THE
PRESIDENT EARLIER SAYING THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA MUST
NEVER, EVER ALLOW IRAN TO HAVE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
HERE WITH REACTION, THE HOST OF
THE RTV, HE'S THE HOST RIGHT
HERE OF THE NUMBER ONE SHOW
SUNDAY NIGHTS, 10:00 P.M. AND
ALL OF CABLE.
LIFE LIBERTY AND LEVIN.
I CALL HIM THE GREAT ONE MARK
LEVIN.
I'M GONNA PUT YOU ON AND TALK
ABOUT THE STORY.
I FORCED YOU TO DO RADIO.
LET'S BE HONEST ABOUT THIS.
I DON'T WANT TO DO IT, AND I
MADE YOU DO IT FOR ME.
I MADE YOU WORK FOR FREE FOR A
YEAR ON WEEKENDS.
THAT'S ONE OF THE HIGHLIGHTS OF
MY CAREER, MY FRIEND.
HOW ARE YOU?
NEVER BEEN DIFFERENT.
>> Sean: MARK, WHEN I READ THE
JUDGE ON FRIDAY, I THOUGHT OF
YOU.
YEARS AGO, HE WROTE AN
INCREDIBLE BOOK CALLED "MEN IN
BLACK."
YOU WROTE THE LIBERTY --
AMERICAN TYRANNY.
LIBERTY VERSUS TYRANNY.
>> SO MANY OF THEM.
STAY WHEN THEY ARE ALL GREAT
BOOKS.
YOUR CONSTITUTIONAL SCHOLAR.
YOU SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING.
YOU'VE HEARD WHETHER THE JUDGE
SAID FRIDAY.
THEY ARE PUTTING THE SCREWS TO
PAUL MANAFORT.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
COLLUSION.
THEY WANT HIM TO SING.
BE CAREFUL.
HE MAY NOT JUST SAYING.
HE MAY COMPOSE.
I WAS PROUD OF THAT JUDGE
BECAUSE THAT JUDGE NAILED IT.
NOW YOU SEE SARA CARTER'S REPORT
TONIGHT.
COMEY AND MUELLER COORDINATING.
TELL ME WHY THIS IS SO BIG.
>> LET'S HOPE THE JUDGE IS NOT
JUST A GASBAG AND DOES SOMETHING
ABOUT WHAT HE SAYS.
LET'S DRAG US ALL BACK, FOR A
FEW MINUTES, TO THE
CONSTITUTION.
BECAUSE THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE,
THIS IS WHERE IT'S GOING TO WIND
UP.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVE TO ANSWER
SOME FUNDAMENTAL QUESTIONS ABOUT
THIS INVESTIGATION.
MR. MUELLER WANTS TO INTERVIEW
THE PRESIDENT COMMITTEE WANTS TO
INTERVIEW HIM UNDER THE MOST
ONEROUS CIRCUMSTANCE.
WHAT IS THE PURPOSE OF AN
INTERVIEW LIKE THAT BASED ON
THOSE 49 GENERAL AREAS?
'S PURPOSE IS TO INDICT THE
PRESIDENT.
NOW, WHAT'S THE PURPOSE OF
INDICTING THE PRESIDENT, TO TRY
THE PRESIDENT FIND HIM GUILTY.
WHAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THE
CONVICTION?
TO REMOVE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES FROM OFFICE.
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
NO PRESIDENT HAS EVER BEEN
INDICTED WHILE IN OFFICE.
NOT ONE.
NO PRESIDENT HAS EVER BEEN
FORCED BEFORE A FEDERAL GRAND
JURY, NOT ONE.
NO PRESIDENT HAS EVER BEEN
REMOVED FROM OFFICE BY THE
UNITED STATES SENATE IN A
TWO-THIRDS VOTE OF THE SENATE.
NOT ONE.
MUELLER'S PURPOSE, HIS PURPOSE
IS TO REMOVE THE PRESIDENT.
THAT MEANS ONE MAN, THAT MEANS
ONE MAN, ONE JURY WOULD USURP
THE POWER, THE ENTIRE
CONSTITUTIONAL POWER OF
CONGRESS.
THE POWER TO REMOVE A PRESIDENT.
YOU CAN INDICT EVERY OTHER
PUBLIC OFFICIAL.
A JUDGE, FOR INSTANCE, WHILE
THEY ARE IN OFFICE, AND GO
THROUGH THE IMPEACHMENT PROCESS.
YOU CANNOT DO IT WITH A
PRESIDENT, AND I'M GOING TO TELL
YOU I'VE BEEN STARTING THIS FOR
DECADES.
I'M STARTING IT NOW.
HERE'S THE AUTHORITATIVE BOOK.
SO WHAT'S GOING ON NOW?
TAKES TWO-THIRDS OF THE SENATE
TO REMOVE A PRESIDENT.
NOT ONE PROSECUTOR, NOT ONE
JURY.
SO MY QUESTION IS, FROM A
CONSTITUTIONAL PERSPECTIVE, TO
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS
COMMITS TIME TO STEP UP.
TO THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL,
IT'S TIME TO PAY ATTENTION.
TO THE ENTIRE COUNTRY, TO ALL
THE LAWYERS YOU BRING ON YOUR
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE NOW, THESE
FIGHTS OVER WHETHER HE'S
GOING TO BE SUBPOENAED, THE
PRESIDENT, WHETHER HE'S GOING TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS, WHETHER HE CAN
BE INDICTED IN OFFICE, I WANT
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND THAT THE
FRAMERS NEVER EVEN CONTEMPLATED
WHAT'S GOING ON TODAY.
THEY NEVER CONTEMPLATED THAT ONE
PROSECUTOR, A CIVIL SERVANT,
BUREAUCRAT APPOINTED BY SOMEBODY
ELSE, WOULD HAVE THE POWER TO
EFFECTIVELY REMOVE THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
THE REASON WHY THE DEMOCRATS ARE
HANGING THEIR HAT ON MUELLER,
THE REASON WHY THE MEDIA ARE
THEY WILL NEVER GET TWO-THIRDS
IN THE SENATE TO REMOVE THIS
PRESIDENT.
I DON'T CARE IF THEY IMPEACH
HIM.
THEY WILL NEVER GET TWO-THIRDS.
IT'S NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE.
SO WHAT THEY ARE HOPING TO DO IS
TRAP HIM IN THIS NOTION OF A
SUBPOENA AND QUESTIONING, INDICT
HIM, TRY TO HUMILIATE HIM.
GO IN FRONT OF A COURT, HOPE
THEY THINK GET THE SUPREME COURT
ON THEIR SIDE BUT I DOUBT THEY
WILL BUT YOU NEVER KNOW.
THAT'S OUR GAME PLAN.
GET HIM TO RESIGN.
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT.
FROM A CONSTITUTIONAL
PERSPECTIVE, AS I SPEAK,
MR. MUELLER IS UNDERMINING THE
CONSTITUTION.
HE'S NOT UPHOLDING THE RULE OF
LAW.
WHETHER HE IS CONSULTING WITH
COMEY OR CONSULTING WITH
NOSTRADAMUS, MY POINT IS THIS.
WHAT'S GOING ON RIGHT NOW LEE'S
ANTI-CONSTITUTIONAL.
IT'S UNDERMINING OUR SYSTEM.
THE FRAMERS WANTED THE BODY
POLITIC TO DECIDE ON WHETHER OR
NOT TO REMOVE ONE BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT.
JUST AS THE BODY POLITIC PUT
THAT PERSON THERE IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
THE MEDIA ARE TOO IGNORANT, TOO
LIBERAL, TOO OBSESSED TO
UNDERSTAND THIS, BUT I AM HOPING
TONIGHT WITH A FEW MINUTES HERE,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WELL.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, I CALL YOU
THE GREAT ONE.
ONE OF THE BEST THINGS, OUR
GREATEST ACCOMPLISHMENT IN MY
LIFE WAS CONVINCING YOU TO FILL
IN FOR MY RADIO SHOW, AND IT DID
TAKE CONVINCING.
WASN'T EASY.
MARK, YOUR KNOWLEDGE OF OUR
FRAMERS AND OUR FOUNDERS IN OUR
CONSTITUTION IS SECOND NOBODY.
THESE WORDS TONIGHT ARE
IMPORTANT.
I AGREE WITH EVERYONE OF THEM.
WE LOVE HAVING YOU ON.
DON'T FORGET EVERY SUNDAY NIGHT,